hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and the mha manga
just gave us possibly the biggest
controversy in the history of the series
a lot of fans are mad for a variety of
different reasons the quality of the
current mha arc is being dragged all
over social media and just in general
the entire fandom has completely lost
its mind even more so than usual
although i'm a bit reluctant to dive
into the absolute chaos that is the mha
manga in fandom right now breaking it
all down for you is my job so let's get
into it before we get started a quick
warning about scammers in the comments
there have been some scam accounts in
our anime opera comments offering
special deals or giveaways or things
like that if you follow anime uproar on
like telegram or some other apps we do
not have a telegram and any giveaway
that we might be organizing we will be
mentioning directly in our videos not in
the comments please don't fall for these
scammers i will keep banning them from
the channel whenever i see them but
they're bought so they keep popping up
be careful if you're not a bot or
scammer leave a like on this video to
help with that youtube algorithm and of
course subscribe for more videos in the
future finally this video will of course
contain boku hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay so obviously for the
past several chapters everyone has been
talking about bakugou and his apparent
death
bakugo's heart had been literally ripped
to pieces under the strain of his battle
against shigaraki and so naturally he
had no pulse his heart stopped beating
he stopped breathing and clinically
speaking he died
some people loved this twist because
they thought that horikoshi's decision
to kill off such an important and
popular character was bray and they felt
that this would really show that there
is tension in mha and that even popular
characters are not safe other people
were extremely upset about this because
they love bakugou and they did not want
him to die under any circumstances
others still myself included were
convinced that this death would turn out
to be a fake out and that bakugou would
be brought back to life the only
question was how exactly was horikoshi
going to do it there were a lot of crazy
theories going around from eddie showing
up and using rewind to bakugou somehow
traveling back in time to become the
second one for all user to my personal
theory that best genius would use his
fiber master quirk to sew bakugou's
heart back together and then someone
with an electric quirk like maybe
kaminari would shock his heart back to
life and get it to start beating again
well chapter 364 arrived and let me tell
you many fans are not very happy and
that is putting it mildly yes of course
bakugou is about to be brought back to
life and his death will turn out to have
been a fake out that seems practically
certain at this point but the way that
this is going to be accomplished makes
very little sense to most people to be
clear there are still fans out there who
are completely fine with everything that
is happening in this chapter and let's
be real there are fans who will try to
justify literally anything and
everything that happens in the manga
they like we cover a bunch of different
series on this channel and we've seen
this same thing with black clover with
one piece with seven deadly sins with
boruto and many many more for some
people even the smallest critique of
their favorite series is a crime and
that's something you just have to accept
but even though there are definitely
people out there who don't mind these
recent events at all a majority of fans
do seem to be upset at least to some
extent and social media has been blowing
up with criticism of the recent
developments in the manga of the quality
of the writing in this final arc and of
horikoshi's entire approach to the final
saga of the story i also personally have
some legitimate criticisms of this
chapter and i will be breaking those
criticisms down openly and honestly but
at the same time i understand that this
is a shonen story that appeals to a
teenage demographic and that this is
horikoshi's story that he can do
whatever he wants with i've heard about
people actually tagging horikoshi on
twitter and attacking him or even
threatening him because they didn't like
how the recent events of the manga
unfolded at the end of the day this is a
fictional story with completely
fictional characters and if you hate it
you can always just tune out anger and
threats over fictional drawings is just
pointless and stupid but anyway i want
to start off on a positive note because
there was one part of the latest chapter
that i thought was actually good i'm
referring to how all for one's ability
to rewind himself back to his prime was
explained and also the drawbacks that
this process has for all for one once he
decides to activate it basically dr
uchiko used the quirk cancelling bullets
in order to replicate the effects of
aries quirk because the bullets
themselves were created using aries dna
and the effects of her quirk rewind all
for one explains that he wasn't planning
on playing this final trump card against
endeavour so he congratulates endeavor
on forcing him to resort to this the
reason why all41 wasn't planning on
using it is because it was intended to
be a weapon of last resort due to the
staggering consequences that it has on
the user's body namely by using this
process all for one was able to rewind
his body to its prime but once that
process of rewinding is initiated all
for one's body will eventually rewind
itself out of existence this means that
the original all for one is now as
strong as he's ever been but as a result
the time he has left is severely limited
this doesn't concern him because he
already transplanted his consciousness
into shigeraki's body so his main goal
now is to weaken the heroes as much as
possible in order to ensure shigaraki's
ultimate victory when we initially saw
that all for one was reverting back to
his prime i was quite concerned about
how absolutely broken this was going to
make him i mean he was already super
strong even in his severely injured
older body but now that he's back in his
prime his body feels as light as silk
his speed is unbelievable and he is able
to steal the quirks of heroes in an
instant he also declares that the one
piece is real before actually putting on
some clothes all for one is an absolute
menace right now and all the heroes on
that battlefield including hawks
tokoyami and endeavour should be
seriously concerned for their lives that
said there is still hope because as i
said all for once time is limited and if
the heroes can just buy enough time then
all for one will be rewound out of
existence and they will win so yeah i
actually really liked how horikoshi
handled this insane power-up for all for
one it is extremely broken but it is
also temporary and using it means that
over one has already sacrificed his own
life
and that is pretty much where my praise
for this chapter ends almost instantly
after all for one explains the sacrifice
that he has just made hawks decides to
buy some time by asking all for one what
his dream truly is since earlier over
one was talking about his dream living
on through tomorrow after he himself
ceases to exist the answer he gives is
so dumb that i honestly had to wait for
the official translation before
commenting on it because i thought that
the unofficial translation may have made
some terrible mistake but no
no
all for one basically says that he's
quite influenced by comics which is like
okay
and then he says that in comics the
world always fears the big bad villain
hawks is like yeah because the villains
do bad stuff and all for one responds by
saying what counts as bad stuff
the rest of what all for one says i will
have to quote word for word from the
official viz.com translation just so
there isn't any confusion in terms of
what he's saying and what i'm
interpreting on my own all for one says
and i quote in a world teeming with
myriad cultures and values bad stuff
would be an act that universally makes
the masses turn up their noses in
disgust an act which towards the future
they envision so
i intend to twart the future of the
whole world
that's all
i've ever wished for please help me out
here and comment down below what you
think of one is actually saying because
to me it just sounds like his entire big
dream is to troll the whole world oh you
have ideas about a bright future that
you envision well i'm gonna troll you by
making sure that future never happens
cope suckers there is no mention here of
trying to empower people with quirks who
were shunned by society or discriminated
against in the past there is no mention
of trying to get even with those who
wronged him personally so a standard
revenge motive there is no mention of
wanting money and power and control it's
all about trolling the world and
towarding the future they envision it's
like that one guy who just spams 18 plus
images in a public discord server in
order to ruin the whole experience for
everyone like i know that not every
villain has to have a deeply
philosophical motivation but man did all
for one really go through like multiple
lifetimes of scheming and plotting and
fighting and suffering just because he
likes comics and wants to troll the
world please guys help me out in the
comments because i want to understand
what horikoshi was going for here i
really do the comics part could have
been promising but at this point i wish
he had said i want to be the hokage or
the pirate king rather than what he
ended up actually saying then we get a
brief section of the chapter that takes
place in the united states which also
seems to be dealing with similar civil
unrest and villain activity as japan the
living breathing star wars reference
admiral akbar is trying to convince the
president of the united states to attack
shigaraki right now while he's still
busy dealing with the japanese heroes
the president seems to believe that
chicago is already too strong to be
stopped so they should actually try to
appease him and make a deal with him in
order to minimize casualties the
president says that he does plan to
eventually strike shigaraki when the
time is right but this doesn't make
sense because the time is right right
now if shigaraki is currently facing off
against the best heroes and hero
students that japan has to offer
wouldn't it make more sense to attack
him now and join forces with the
japanese heroes how is waiting for him
to subjugate all of japan and become
even stronger a smart play i won't get
into the complexities of international
relations here but this type of
appeasement doesn't make much sense and
it has been a disaster historically in
our own world as well shigaraki is not a
rational state actor who can be
bargained with he is an unhinged villain
psycho who just wants to destroy
everything surely you don't expect
chicago to like join the united nations
and host the olympics do you we then get
a couple of pages that emphasize the
sacrifice made by stars and stripes and
talks about how adults inspire children
and how adult heroes have to serve as
positive role models for the next
generation of heroes and all of that is
just a prelude to what is about to
happen back on the ua battlefield where
best genius is still standing over a
lifeless bakugo genus is trying to use
his fibers to repair bakugou's heart but
it seems that he isn't able to pull it
off on his own so headshot shows up he
looks like he's been injured and we
finally get to see his face he says that
he has a lot of experience invading
people's bodies using his quirk which is
called foldabody and so he intends to
enter bakugo's body and repair his heart
from the inside before he does this
though he yells at miroko to keep
fighting in order to buy him time even
if that means sacrificing her own life
in the process listen horikoshi if you
kill off miruko i'm done with you i'm
gonna drop mha and start playing dating
sims instead anyway ed shot then says
that bakugo's life is a life that they
cannot afford to lose because all the
mha merge sales of course and he
proclaims that he will use his quirk to
replace what's missing inside bakugou's
heart and he will then make bakugo's
heart pump again genus responds by
saying that if headshot does this he
will apparently die as a result but
headshot is just like all good my man i
leave the rest to you then we get
literally a single panel that takes up a
quarter of a page that is supposed to i
guess establish a previous relationship
between headshot and genius genius was
apparently the president of a textile
club that headshot was also a part of in
high school
what
the final page features headshots
stating that he will be the boy's heart
as he uses his quirk to enter bakugo's
body and that is unironically how the
chapter ends so apparently from what we
have gathered so far headshot the number
four pro hero is going to sacrifice his
life in order to literally become
bakugo's heart at a time when the heroes
are dangerously understaffed and
outnumbered the fourth strongest pro
hero is going to die so that a hero
student can live
because bakugo's life is one we can't
afford to lose for some reason like bro
i understand that bakugou is a popular
character and that he's friends with
deku but in the wider world of mha who
cares about bakugo i understand that
deku's life is precious because he's the
user one for all and the top heroes are
precious because they're the ones needed
to fight the villains but bakugou is not
even the strongest hero student he does
not have a special quirk that all for
one is desperate to steal so why is his
life one that we can't afford to lose
again i'm not talking about from the
perspective of the fandom because
obviously we know bakugou is a character
and we like him i'm talking from the
perspective of the wider world of mha
from the perspective of the top heroes
from the perspective of the japanese
government the japanese public and so on
why would headshot who to my knowledge
barely even knows bakugou decide to
sacrifice his life for this kid instead
of fighting the villains as one of the
top pro heroes honestly i have no idea
what is going on here i really hope we
will get somewhat better explanations of
what's happening in the next chapter is
ed shot really about to die or is he
going to somehow live inside of bakugou
and then bakugo will become two people
at once why is bakugo's life so
important to their heroes as compared to
the life of any other hero or hero
student why should any of us even care
if headshot dies since we know almost
nothing about him and neither does
bakugo if anything genus sacrificing
himself would have made a lot more sense
since he actually has a connection to
bakugou like yes i understand the
general argument that heroes should try
to set a good example and rescue other
people even at the cost of their own
life but this is not an ordinary
situation the heroes are currently
facing a villain apocalypse and
protecting the strongest heroes so that
they can live to fight another day
should be the top priority here
protecting every hero student at the
expense of the top heroes is a terrible
combat strategy again deku is an
exception because of one for all but
come on so yeah while i obviously don't
support the people who actually got mad
about this chapter and sent threats to
horikoshi because that's just ridiculous
and unacceptable i can't say that i
liked this chapter there were several
glaring issues in my opinion including
all for one's weird motivations the
strange geopolitical calculations of the
us president and finally the whole
headshot bakugou twist feel free to drop
me a line down in the comments and
explain to me why this chapter was
actually better than i thought because
i'd love to hear what i'm missing i was
mostly on board with what's happening in
this arc it wasn't perfect but it had
potential and i fully expected bakugo to
survive but the way that it's been
handled seems pretty bad and now i'm
genuinely concerned about how this thing
will end oh and for those of you who
think that maybe headshot will fail and
bakugou won't be brought back i wouldn't
bet on that fam i really wouldn't
comment below with all your hot takes
and if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to leave a like and subscribe to
the channel if you disagreed with
everything i said in this video and you
thought that the video itself was
terrible then at least subscribe so you
can be notified when my next video goes
live and you can go and dislike that
video as well and leave a snarky comment
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys